defendants in the College Admission
scandal are maintaining their innocence
when they appear in federal court today
a dozen coaches university
administrators and others facing
racketeering charges pleaded not guilty
yesterday before Boston Judge more than
two dozen parents are scheduled to make
court appearances before the end of the
next week one attorney says the
indictment does not tell the whole story
Carter Evans is at the federal
courthouse in Boston Carter good morning
good morning a lot of people connected
to this investigation are gonna be here
in federal court this weekend there
could be more indictments to come now
the alleged mastermind of this scheme
Rick singer says he worked with nearly
800 families but only 33 parents have
been charged one of them paying at least
six and a half million dollars one by
one top college coaches and
administrators stepped into an
unfamiliar court the tennis coach from
Georgetown and the water polo coach from
USC are among the twelve who pled not
guilty Monday accused of taking bribes
to get undeserving students into some of
the nation's most elite schools the
attorney for the Wake Forest University
volleyball coach accused of taking
$100,000 to accept a wait-listed student
says his client does not belong on the
indictment no one was admitted to Wake
Forest who didn't earn it as a student
and as an athlete Donna heinel is the
former associate athletic director at
USC she's accused of taking bribes to
designate more than two dozen students
as recruited athletes including the
daughters of actress Lori Laughlin and
her husband Massimo Chia newly there are
a lot of people who want to know why
these people got into classes and when
they weren't able to
in a statement Hiles attorney says these
charges come as a complete shock we look
forward to reviewing the government's
evidence and fully restoring Donna's
reputation
Gregory Colburn is one of the indicted
parents and for the first time we're
hearing from his attorney Colburn and
his wife Amy are accused of paying
singers foundation 25 thousand dollars
to have a Proctor take the SATs for
their son their apparent admission
recorded you know
wiretap conversation with singer but
their attorney tells CBS News their son
took the test himself and says there's
no evidence the proctor corrected his
answers I don't think it's fair to say
that this case is a slam dunk even
though they have an insider
he's a vulnerable insider and those
wiretaps what we know now may not tell
the whole story
now Yale is officially the first goal to
wristed admission to a student connected
to this whole scheme many of the parents
are going to be here in court this week
but also next week in two of the highest
profile defendants of the case will be
in court next week that's actress Lorie
Lachlan and Felicity Huffman Gayle all
right Carter thank you very much